It's buffering, and we're live.
Hi everyone, yep, my name's Mark,
I'm a coach at Udacity, and.
>> I'm Andy, I'm helping guide
you through this Nanodegree.
>> Awesome, yes, so today will be
having a live coding session with Andy,
specifically about Python.
So last week we had a coding session
with Andy about HTML and CSS, right?
>> Yeah.
>> And now, and
now we are diving into
the world of Python program.
Now before we start having
Andy do our coding session,
I want to have a little
announcement specially for
Windows users who are having trouble
submitting their projects in our portal.
There was an error for Windows users.
They could not submit their file for
grading.
That has been resolved.
So, our engineers just fixed it today.
They're pushing the code live to our
production servers right now, so,
at the end of today, please resubmit
your file, again, and it should work.
Now, if it does not work,
please let us know on the forums, or
email us at
introprogramming-support@udacidy.com.
Once again, it's
introprogramming-support@udacitycom.
Okay, great now I'm just
going to hand over to Andy.
>> All right, so the purpose of this
live coding session is to walk through
how I think about solving large
problems that involves programming.
I've heard a lot of
feedback in the forums,
especially people who've made it
a decent ways through the second course.
That you can read the code that
somebody else has written,
you can see the solutions,
sort of get what it does, but
have a hard time coming up
with an answer on your own.
And that's very normal,
that is a stage of learning to
program that you go through.
This stuff takes a lot of practice and
it's going to take a lot of time before
you get to the point where
you can create problems, or
create solutions to big problems on your
own in any reasonable amount of time,
but it comes with practice.
And one way to get that practice is to
see how other people go about solving
those problems, and so
that's what we're going to do today.
If you're in the most recent cohort,
the one that began in March,
you're probably still thinking
about HTML, and that's fine.
This may not be as useful for
you as it is for people who have
already started working on Python.
It may be a little useful,
seeing how I think about decomposing
a big problem into smaller pieces.
But it's going to be hard to follow
along, so keep that in mind.
Next week we'll do something
a little more HTML-friendly.
But for now,
we're going to do this in Python, and so
let me share my screen, so we can.
>> Let me know when you share it so
I can,
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Put you online.
Let's see.
All right, you're sharing your screen.
>> All right, so
the problem we want to solve today
is writing something that we check to
see if a Sudoku solution is correct.
I chose this because you can represent
a Sudoku puzzle pretty easily
as it's just a list of lists.
And I know that depending on how far
in the nanodegree you are so far,
you know what lists are and
you have some familiarity with that.
If you don't, that's okay, follow along
or save, come back to this video later.
But Sudoku, it's a puzzle,
you get a grid that's partially
filled out with numbers.
And the goal,
you can see the red numbers here.
You have to fill it out in such a way
that as you go across all of the rows,
you use the numbers 1 through 9.
As you go down all the columns,
So in this column you'll see 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, and 9.
And then, likewise, there's all these,
you see these nine squares.
Square 0, square 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Sorry, I counted from 0.
That’s me being a Python person.
But you can tell that each of these
squares also uses the numbers 1 to 9.
So, I just phrased to
you how to check and
see if a solution is correct in Sudoku,
right?
Check the rows, check the columns,
check the squares.
How do we do that with programming?
How do we begin to approach
this giant problem?
So let me pull up Sublime Text.
And feel free to ask
questions along the way.
Mark's keeping an eye on the forum,
what you guys are saying so
if there's any questions,
I'll try and get to them.
So I hope you can see this.
>> Yeah, it looks pretty good.
>> It's good?
>> Yeah.
>> So I wrote down three steps that I
like to follow when solving a problem.
First I want to understand
the problem and
I'm going to think of understanding
it in terms of inputs and outputs.
This isn't how we think as humans,
but it's how we think as programmers,
because that's how computers think.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Then I'm going to plan a solution, and
I'll show you how to go
about planning a solution.
Then I'm going to fill it out,
and I said fill it out, and
you'll see what I mean by that as we go.
So, first,
let's understand the Sudoku problem.
What are the inputs?
I want to represent a Sudoku puzzle as
a grid like this, and I called this
invalid_grid because this doesn't meet
some of the specifications of Sudoku.
You can tell this grid is a list.
So, here is the outermost
brackets to the list, and
inside that list,
I have nine lists, one, two,
three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine.
And you can probably guess how this is
supposed to represent that Sudoku board.
I didn't represent any squares in
here yet but that was a choice,
we'll get to that later.
And this code down here,
I just found a valid Sudoku puzzle.
So this solution actually check out the
rows have the correct number of numbers,
the columns do to and
the same with the squares, all right?
So I understand the inputs in
the case of the Sudoku puzzle.
I'll say it's a list of lists and
maybe I would give an example but
I did that down here in invalid grid,
and then the outputs.
Well, all I want to know is if a given
input is a good solution to a Sudoku,
or if it's not.
So, true or false.
That's how it's going to output.
I might have some print statements along
the way to help me as I think about
debugging this thing, but
we'll get to that in a second.
Now, let's plan a solution,
and since I don't have paper,
I'm going to opt for
this pretend code version.
Let me show you what that means.
So I'm going to write code,
and I'm going to pretend
like I have access to functions
that I haven't even written yet.
And that turns out, for me,
to be a really helpful way to
approach these big problems.
Instead of diving into the details
first, I'm going to make a function.
Let me just mark it in there.
I'm going to call it check_sudoku.
It's going to take as
input a sudoku_grid.
Now, what do I want this
check_sudoku function to do?
Let's see.
Well, I want it to return
true if it's a valid Sudoku.
So how will I tell if
it's a valid Sudoku?
What we talked about earlier, we need
to check the rows, the columns, and
the squares.
So I'm going to write this.
If check_rows(sudoku_grid).
I'm going to write equals True,
you don't actually need that but
I'm going to write that to
make it a little more clear.
And then I'm going to
print just to let me know,
let me keep track what's going on,
that the rows look good.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Then I'm going to check the columns,
check_columns of
the sudoku_grid is True.
I'm also going to print
columns look good.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And then,
I'm going to check the squares.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
There are other ways we could have Could
have written what I'm writing here.
We could have done
this in a single line,
I could have said if check_rows and
check_columns and check_squares.
But I like this, because it's going to
slowly let us see rows are good,
columns, and so on.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Now I can just return true,
because now, we've made it all the way.
This is a valid sudoku grid.
We've checked squares, we checked
the columns, we checked the rows.
But you're probably saying, but
you don't have those functions yet.
You haven't written check rows,
you haven't written check columns.
And that's actually true, and
if I try to run this function now,
print check_sudoku.
Let's look at the VALID_GRID
from up above.
Actually, I'm going to
write these in all caps.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It's a good practice, if you just have
variables hanging out there inside
the function, to write them as all caps.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay, so
let's see what's going to happen.
I'm going to hit on my Mac,
Cmd+B on this.
I think would be probably Ctrl or
Alt+B on Windows machine.
>> Right, yeah, you see that little-
>> And then down here is my output.
>> Yeah.
>> And how am I going to read this?
Okay, let's read through
this from the very top.
Traceback (most recent call last), so
I actually want to go the other way,
I'm going to start at the bottom.
I usually start at the bottom of
on these things, so NameError,
global name check_rows is not defined.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So that means that I called
this function check_sudoku.
It tried to call this, but
of course, it wasn't defined, and
I should have known that
was going to happen.
So, I did know that was going to happen,
but that's the error.
That's okay, let's define it.
In this system of gradually
flushing out your solution,
you start from the biggest picture,
check_sudoku, right?
Just means I'm going to check
the rows,the columns, and the rows.
And then, as your code doesn't run,
you just keep refining it until
it looks like it's working.
So I'm going to write check_rows of,
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I'm just going to actually
[INAUDIBLE] this grid.
I just want it to be clear which
variables are which you can get
confusing me if similar words and
the same parameters and all that.
So this sudoku_grid is a list of lists.
So I can use a for loop,
to go through the rows of that list.
So, for row in grid, and
to show you what that actually does,
let's just print out
each of those rows first.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And,
I'm going to comment this out.
And let's do check_rows(VALID_GRID).
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So you can see, for
row in grid, it prints the row,
and it prints each one on a new line.
You don't see those the brackets
at the very beginning and
the very end because it's just printing
the things inside of that grid
which are the elements of the rows.
Okay, so now I know how to get
access to each of those rows.
Now I'll call each of these numbers
a cell because it seems to make sense,
we have rows, we have columns and
each of these little squares.
The value inside we'll call cell.
So I'm going to do another for
loop, I'm going to do for cell in row.
And just to remind you what
this is going to print,
let's just look at
exactly what this does.
And this is kind of a mess but
you can see 4 3 5 2 6 9,
it's just printing out
each individual letter.
I'm sorry, okay, so,
that's how we iterate through our grid.
Now what do I actually want to do?
I'm checking the row, I want to check
and make sure that each row is valid.
So,
[BLANK_AUDIO]
If, let's say, is_valid_row, and again,
I'm making up a function, of row.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So what do I want to do, actually.
So this is where you have to stop and
think.
I want to go through all of these rows,
and if one of them is bad,
then the whole thing is bad.
And I don't want to return a False.
So actually,
I want to do if is_valid_row.
If any of these are not valid,
it any of them are false,
I'm going to return false.
This is no good.
And
only when I've gone through
this whole for loop and
confirmed that none of them are false,
I haven't returned anything yet.
Only then, will I make it down here and
be able to actually return true.
And if I ran check_rows here,
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I'm getting the is_valid_row
is not defined, as expected.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So, let's just write that def,
is_valid_row.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And I'm going to make.
I have my desired array here.
That's not what I wanted, sorry.
So required_numbers.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
These are the numbers that
I need to see in each row.
I need to see 1,2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
I could have done that using something
called Python's range function, but
I'm going to just write it out for
you guys.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And let's see, what do I want to do?
Let's do for number in required_numbers,
so that's going to go through all
those numbers, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
If that number is not in the row,
that's bad.
That's not a good row, so
it going to return false.
And only if we've gone through and
verified that all of those
numbers are can we return true.
And look!
Now, we've we've gotten somewhere.
We haven't written anything that's fake.
So, in theory, if we check
the rows of something of a grid,
like VALID_GRID, maybe it'll return
true, if we haven't messed up.
Let's do print check_rows.
>> It's true.
>> Cool.
>> That worked.
>> Wow.
>> So
the VALID_GRID has valid rows, at least.
We haven't checked its columns.
Let's actually look at the INVALID_GRID.
>> Yeah, let's check that.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> And that's true, too.
But that's okay.
That doesn't mean our code is bad
because if you look at the in
VALID_GRID, I just made a bunch of 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
So those rows actually are all good.
So that's I mean that's why we
have the column check because
that's not enough for our sudoku.
Okay cool, so
let's zoom out for a second.
Let me pull this down.
There's this thing you
can do in Sublime,
you click these little triangles and
it just collapses everything.
So check_rows gets kind of collapsed
down, check_sudoku gets collapsed down.
I can collapse that,
collapse that, okay.
So let's go back to check_sudoku.
So we've gotten check_rows figured out.
Now we need to do check_columns.
So let's define that function.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
In the meta point, I've collapsed these
functions, I can open them up again by
clicking the green arrow or
that little arrow next to it.
I like leaving them collapsed.
It's just less for
me to have to look at and think about.
Keep my mind like workspace clean.
So check_columns, wow!
How am I going to check_columns?
Rows were a little easier because
the lists themselves were in rows.
>> Mm-hm, that's a very,
very good point.
>> So, this is not, as easy.
So one thing I could do,
I could say well I know I want to
check index zero, whatever of a hero.
>> Yeah.
>> I want to check index one,
want to check index two.
>> That’s a systematic way of thinking.
>> Okay, in case so, so
let's see, I'm going to do,
for index in, and
this is where I'm actually
going to use this range function,
range(9).
I'm going to show you
what range(9) prints out.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Sorry, let me do that right up here.
So I just ran that, this code.
Oops, and, perfect.
Sorry.
[CROSSTALK] So IndentationError,
this happens all the time with Python.
I love Python, other languages use these
curly braces everywhere and brackets and
parentheses and it's easy to forget
those too, but Python it has a problem.
It's easy to mess up you notation.
So let's go to line 61 and
see what the problem is.
So here's 61.
I wrote this for loop but
I don't have anything.
Let me just comment
this whole thing out.
Let me get rid of this, as well.
Okay, so now let's try that again.
Okay, so
range(9) generates a list of all
the numbers between 0 and just up to 9.
One less, so up to 8.
>> Mm-hm.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Okay, so let's do our check_columns.
Where did check_columns go, here
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So what I want to do, so
index'll be 0 and then 1 then 2.
And what I really want
is when index is 0,
I want to check all of
these down at index 0.
And I want to check all
the ones at index one.
Okay, so I could do this with
another pretend function but
I think I'm just
going to write this one.
So let's see.
Up above here,
I'm going to make an empty list,
we're going to call it columns.
And each of these,
I'm going to make a new column.
So I'm going to go over
every row in the grid,
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And first I'm going to
make a new empty column.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And for every row in the grid, I'm
going to get whatever the value is at
that index, so either 0 or
1 or 2 or whatever.
And I'm going to add
it to my new column.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So, that's going to be row of index.
Now, the code we have here,
this line of code.
The only reason I could write this so
quickly and I'm not even sure it's
going to work but I think it will, but
the only reason I can write this so
quickly is because I've written lines
similar to this 100 times before.
I've thought of going
through lists of lists and
keeping track of an index and
if this looks very foreign or
how do you ever come up with it
the answer is just practice.
It's a new language,
Python is a new language for
you and like anything,
fluency comes with practice.
But here we go.
So I'm going to add the right entry,
that's row at index,
to my new column and actually gone
through every row in the grid.
I'm going to add my new column.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I'm going to add my new
column to these columns,
because now what I have is these.
Let's just print columns so we can show
you what we've done here, if this works.
So I'm going to take back this invalid
grid, which is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8,
9, and so on.
And I'm going to see what happens
when I do check_columns on that.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It's not actually checking the columns.
It's not complete.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Any guesses on what
it's going to return?
>> [SOUND] I guess, yeah.
>> Okay, let me try this one more time.
Actually let's do for column in, because
it was giving me this whole list.
>> Yeah.
>> I just want to print out each
column one time.
>> Column.
>> And I'm going to make this return.
>> There we go.
You've basically converted
all the columns into.
>> Wait, let me get rid of this line,
that’s confusing.
>> Where’s that line?
>> That’s the range Iine.
>> Okay, okay.
>> So, see what we had, before we had
ones going all the way down this side,
and now we have ones going
all the way along the top.
The reason I did this is because
I know how to check rows.
I've already written the function.
So now I'm actually not going to return
in the columns, I'm just going to return
check_rows on those columns
because I know how to do that.
So let's see what happens when we check
the Sudoku VALID_GRID at this point and
let me get to this.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay, rows look good,
the columns look good.
So it looks like this check_columns
function and I should let you all know,
I wrote this code before we did this.
And there were a lot
of bugs along the way.
I do not want you to think this
is how the coding process works.
This took me a long
time to figure it out,
and I'm just showing you, in a shortened
form, how I thought about it.
Normally, there'd be a ton of errors.
There were a ton of errors.
That's how it actually goes.
So, okay.
The rows look good and
the columns look good.
So let's zoom out again,
I'm a big fan of zooming out.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
All right, we've got a function
called check_sudoku.
It takes its input, the grid,
that looks something like this,
a list of lists, and it goes through.
First it checks the rows
to make sure that they each have
the values one through nine.
Then it goes through and
checks the columns to make sure that
each of the values one through nine.
Then it goes through and, well, soon it
will go through and check the squares.
We can see in our traceback error,
[BLANK_AUDIO]
All the way down here, global name
check_squares is not defined,
check_squares not defined.
Right, I hadn't defined it yet.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So, it looks like we know
what we have to do next.
Let me just put these all next to each
other, so we can see them all on screen.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
This is useless.
I don't know why this
is floating around.
So, you can see what we mean by
filling out our solution, by the way.
So, this is us planning
slash filling it out.
We're writing code hoping that we
have functions later, but we don't.
So this check_squares function,
I'm going to tell you in advance,
took me a long time to figure out.
So if I have a grid and
I'm going to call this a grid that's
nine by nine.
And the reason I'm going to do that
to distinguish this sudoku grid from
the grid of squares which
are three by three.
So how I'm going to check the squares?
So, let's see,
let's go back to our what it like.
There's a few ways we could do this,
I think what I want to do is I want
to first get this in square form.
And what is square form
going to look like?
Well, that's a good question.
I think I'm going to think of this as,
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Here, we're going to have a row of three
squares, so the biggest list is going to
contain Three rows, with these three,
they each have these three squares.
This is going to be the first one,
that would be the second one, and
this would be the third one.
Then each of those, those three rows
are going to have three squares.
So, this one's going to have
the square that's on here.
[INAUDIBLE].
I don't know how to highlight it that
way, but, it's going to have this,
this, and this, and then each of
the squares are going to have rows, and
each of those rows
are going to have entries.
So, that's going to make a list,
of lists, of lists, of lists.
If you didn't want to do it that way,
there's other ways to do it.
This is the way I'm going to do it.
You can go as deep as you want.
You can have as many lists
inside of lists as you want, and
I kind of like this approach, so.
How are we going to to do it?
Okay so, we said that this full grid
is made of rows of three squares.
So, for row_of_3_squares, remember,
each of the squares is three by three.
Sorry.
The grid is just a thing, man.
I have to make squares first?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So, I'm going to just try and convert
this grid, this nine by nine grid.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Into a row of squares.
Then,
[BLANK_AUDIO]
For row, for each of those, row,
I'm going to have three
squares in each of those rows.
So, I'm going to iterate over
those squares, for square.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And now,
I'm going to check that square, so that
square should be a three by three grid.
Basically, it should
look similar to this.
Let me just give you one example.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
EXAMPLE_SQUARE would be
something like 1, 2, 3.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
[4,5,6], [7,8,9].
And that would, as just a square
that would be [INAUDIBLE], so
[INAUDIBLE] squares look like.
So, I now I'm going to do that thing
where I pretend I have a function, so
I'm going to do if check_ square.
Notice, that's just a single square.
There's no s on the end here,
so it's a different function.
And I'm just going refer to this square,
it's the same one.
So if that's false, doesn't matter,
when one square's bad,
the whole puzzle's bad.
I can return false.
And if I've gotten through
every square in every row,
only then can I return true.
[SOUND], okay, this is a lot, and
I'm not going to keep going with this,
because I know this is hard
to follow at this point.
The reason I'm able to do this
quickly is because, like I said,
I kind of thought about this already.
But let me show you what my
solution code looked like.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay, that looks similar.
Check rows.
So this is actually,
I had to change my solution because
I'm not really a fan of Sudoku.
So actually earlier, I thought that
the only requirement was that the sum,
the total of each row, had to be-
>> A certain number.
>> 1 plus 2 plus 3 plus 4.
That's not correct,
it actually needs one of each.
>> At least one of each, yeah.
>> So,
I had to modify this a little bit.
>> Yeah.
>> But, let's go with this,
it doesn't change the idea too much.
Check columns, looks a little different.
You can see I've got
these print statements.
Those are there because
I had to debug this.
I didn't put them in while I
was solving it from memory,
because I didn't need them.
I remembered what the solution was, and
I had just gone through all
these problems an hour ago.
But these were here to show me where
in the code things are failing.
It wasn't working, and I didn't
know why, and I needed those there.
So, my check_squares function.
Okay, so, I call it get_squares
instead of make_squares, but
similar sort of thing.
The check_square function,
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It goes through each row
in a three by three.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Again, remember, this is me thinking you
just had to add up to some desired sum,
so this would require some modification.
>> Right.
>> Else return False.
>> For those of you who are a little bit
confusing, we'll be sure to post this.
>> Yeah,
we're going to definitely post this.
>> We'll post this code
along with comments and
the way that we're thinking, so don't
worry if you're trying to feverishly
understand every line of code.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> Just make sure that you
understand the bigger concept of,
here we are, we are like-
>> This is the bigger concept, right?
>> This is the bigger concept, yeah.
>> The steps for solving a problem.
>> Basically, that's the main thing
that we want you to get away from this
exercise-
>> Yeah.
>> Really.
So Andy, do you want to have anything
else to show for this type of code?
>> I think maybe I'm going to stop
sharing my screen so I can look,
actually.
>> Okay, we are broadcasting
live on this cam right now.
Okay, great.
Yeah, so, we will for sure post
this code, so you could follow along and
follow along the thinking process.
That's the most important thing, and
the main thing is really, specifically
we break things down, right?
>> Yeah.
We have a little more time.
Can I quickly show you
how I would apply this.
>> Yeah, you need to do screenshare.
>> Yeah.
>> Hold it, yeah, you switched already.
>> Okay.
>> We're good.
Okay, we're good.
>> Okay.
So, if you've gotten through stage two,
to work session five.
Let's just do this from scratch.
This applies so
well to this last problem,
where, what was the problem?
>> Generate concept, HTML?
>> I already set this.
Okay, so this is where I wanted to,
I'm just going to get rid of all this.
I want to write a function called
make_HTML from any concepts.
because what I wanted to do was I wanted
to stop having Copy and Paste my divs.
I want to be able to
specify the concepts I want
in my my notes in one place.
And just modify that instead
of having to keep modifying my
actual HTML file by Copy and
Pasting which is error prone.
So for example, let's say,
I had Python, so
I'm just going to keep these very
minimal for illustration and
then maybe it had another
entry that was HTML.
I'll do, Stands for
HyperText Markup Language.
Okay so
this is my choice of data structure.
It's called for
how I want to represent concepts.
Each concept is a list,
each list has a title.
[INAUDIBLE] sorry, sorry.
No.
Has a title and a description,
title, description.
And so, applying the same thought
process to solving this problem.
I would say all right, let's do, Jeff,
what was it called, make_HTML_for_me.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Many_concepts and
it's going to take Concept_list.
I'm just calling it something
different to distinguish it from this
even though I'm eventually going to
call this function with this argument.
This can be tricky.
There's a lot of stuff
floating around but
I'm going to just call it concept_list.
Okay, so what do I want to do?
So, first, I want to iterate over this
big list that's in green right now.
So, I'm going to do for
concept in concept_list.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Hm, no, I'm making HTML, and
I want that as a string, so
I should have to remember, I'm going to
first start with an empty string.
And I'm going to just
keep adding to that.
So let's what do we going to add?
I'm going to add HTML is going to
equal whatever the previous HTML was,
which right now is this.
But remember it's not always going to be
this as we look through we're going to
be making this bigger and
bigger so make.
I'm going to call this function
make_html_for_concept,
I forgot what it was actually called,
and
that's going to take a single
concept as far as an argument.
And remember,
single concept is a list like that.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And then I'm going to return HTML.
So, that looks pretty simple, right?
This code is nice and readable.
I know I have to go and find or
create make_html_for_concept, but
I can go through.
I can read through this.
And sort of get what's going on and
somebody else could too.
In fact someone else is you in a week
because it can often be hard to
read your code a week later.
Now I need to make this function.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I just wanted to do a little commentary,
as Andy's coding.
See, Andy's actually
breaking things down, and
he's actually doing this
exercise called pseudocode, and
he's actually thinking and
writing down as he types.
And he's actually breaking things down
and actually creating these functions
and naming them in a way that makes
sense in the regular English language.
>> Thanks for doing that because I
have a lot of just boilerplate code to
write itself.
>> Yes, if you can keep riffing it.
>> Yeah, exactly, so basically, really
it's a really good way for you to start
thinking okay, how can I transfer
what's in my head to what's on paper?
And then what's on paper to something
that the computer program could
actually go and understand.
So, the first step is to think about,
again, like understand the bigger issue,
like what is the question?
What is it that we're trying to do?
What are the inputs that we're getting,
and what are our outputs
that we're supposed to make?
Really, if you think of it,
it's just really that you
are basically the machine, right?
You programmed the machine to take some
sort of input, some sort of raw input,
it does its magic, and then it outputs
the thing that you want, the string or
some sort of result that you want.
So it's good to really just sit down and
think back and zoom out,
what Andy often does.
And really think about, okay,
what are the ins, inputs,
what are the outputs, and what
are the required transformations that I
need to be able to transform
this raw input into this output.
Thank you yes great If you look, okay.
So I think we can go
over this code of a bit.
So here I define with HTML is for
a given concept and so
first I have this div that captures
everything and has a class of concept
inside of that there is div of
the class of concept-title.
And here, ooh.
Actually, I don't like this.
I don't like this concept of zero.
All I know os that if I come
back to this in a week,
I'm going to forget
where that comes from,
so let me just title equals concept.
Concept of zero.
There we go.
What Andy's doing is actually a very
important best practices, that we need
define these helper variables that,
instead of just accessing this array.
Directly, we actually give it
another name, basically, like title,
description, so we know exactly
conceptually what we're trying to do.
>> Yes, so that the previous
code would have worked.
>> Yeah.
>> But working isn't always enough.
I mean, it's enough for
the computer, but
there's two people involved in making
the code and you are one of them.
And you're going to want to
do this again in a week, and
it's going to be much,
you're going to love yourself.
If you just were nice enough to
give things very descriptive names.
>> Yeah, I love the fact that Andy's
saying program for your future self.
I often tell my students that.
Listen, you need to program for
your future self and
make your future self love you,
like in the present.
[LAUGH]
>> So, now, in theory,
if I called this function on list
with list of concepts as an input.
It should return some HTML.
So let's do that
make_HTML_for_many_concepts.
And, what was that, (list_of_concepts),
>> It was called process, and
we need to print this out, right,
because this was being disputed.
>> Yes.
Let's just actually,
let's just show what happens
if you don't you don't.
This is one of the most fresh,
there's another [CROSSTALK]
>> [CROSSTALK] global single_concepts
and
>> Where was single.
Okay.
I called this single_concept, but I was
calling it in the for loop just concept.
>> Yeah.
It's just concept.
>> So I'm going to just call it concept.
Okay.
Your code didn't display any output.
>> Yeah.
There's nothing.
>> You don't know how many times I've
looked at that output message, for
hours, before I realized that this
function was returning something.
>> But
return isn't quite the same as print.
I need to print.
>> Yeah, print.
>> And sure enough, when I do that.
>> Nice.
>> It looks pretty nice.
>> Look at that,
auto-generated HTML code.
>> And now, I mean in theory, I could
just keep track of all my notes up here.
And as I add new notes, so
let's say I learned something new about,
like, I don't know,
let's say I learned about,
tomorrow I'm going to learn about
object oriented programming.
Object oriented,
this is what you learn in Course Three,
programming is the best.
And should go, now,
said having a copy and paste.
Boom.
>> There you go, yeah.
>> I’ve got a nice HTML
notoriety properly for.
>> Awesome.
>> That’s the value of
avoiding repetition.
>> Also, we’re screening back for
the video camera.
Hopeful everyone saw some
really good Frameworks,
some true programming way of thinking.
We have a couple of questions.
>> Yeah, yes.
>> We got a couple of minutes like
[INAUDIBLE].
So the first one.
[LAUGH] That was the most
highly uploaded.
I’m late coming to office hours.
Can you tell me where can I get
the recording for this once and
also the once in the past?
So basically after this office
hours has been, is finished,
Google will actually
automatically record this video.
So what you need to do is just,
after we end this session,
go back to the same page.
Refresh your page And
then you can actually start from
start playing at the beginning.
So all office hour sessions
will be on the Google Events
site as well as in the discussion forum.
So after every office hours,
we go into the discussion forums and
actually post a link to the specific
office hour sessions as well as links to
the code that Andy wrote
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So this one is, yeah, Joshua.
Another question is,
please post this code and
the rationale of your Python thinking.
Please tell us where it is posted.
So once again, we will post these on
the discussion forum, the code itself.
So watch out for
that either tonight or tomorrow.
And you could actually go ahead and
Go through the code and
actually try to code it line by line,
the way that Andy did.
So you can actually really
think the way that Andy did.
So now you'd have a-
>> I mean,
that style of thinking
takes practice too.
>> Yeah.
>> I remember,
I first saw this in a Udacity class
called Design of Computer Programs with
an expert programmer named Peter Norvig.
And it blew my mind that he
was thinking this way, but
I loved the way of thinking.
And I loved it enough to
stick with trying it out.
But I really,
it was hard at first to write code for
functions that didn't exist.
But with practice you'll get it.
>> Yeah, so it's a great way to
just think ahead and structure.
>> And avoid details, make sure that
your big picture solution makes sense
before you spend all this time and
energy writing the detailed solutions.
>> Okay, great.
Let's like this question.
Is it true I can use Sublime
2 to write Python code?
Sorry if you've already explained it.
>> Yes, it's absolutely true.
Can I share that screen?
>> Yes, go ahead,
you are screen sharing.
>> All right, so
let's do a new file with Sublime Text.
So I did file, new file.
So right now,
I'm going to float over here.
If you look up on this tab
you just see untitled.
So the first thing you need to do, so
that I can actually code in Python,
is save this file as.
I'm going to save in my
desktop as example code.
But that name doesn't matter, what
matters is what's called the extension.
So I saved as example code.py.
And that tells any program
that knows about Python,
hey this is a Python file,
treat it like a Python file.
And then when I write something
like def it becomes blue.
Def my_function, and
now my function is green.
And the arguments are going to be hm,
orange, I guess.
This is really nice,
this syntax highlighting.
And it's something that you get, because
Sublime understands that this is Python.
If you want to run this code, you can go
to project, or sorry, what is it, tools.
It's actually build and
I didn't [INAUDIBLE] function.
[CROSSTALK]
>> Return.
>> I didn't actually call it.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> This function doesn’t do
anything with its inputs.
It's a pretty terrible function,
but that’s okay.
And sure enough there’s Hello.
It shows up in the bottom.
Yes.
>> So you can totally do that and
that's a good way to code.
If you're struggling with using,
this is a better
place to code than in the Udacity
window that I showed you earlier.
But the Udacity window is good for
short little functions.
But this is nicer because the syntax
highlighting is a little better, and
a few other reasons.
>> Great, thanks for
the question, Joshua.
Roberta had more of a comment,
and this is a very valid comment.
I've been watching from the beginning,
but I'm afraid I'm lost.
This is getting way more complex
than the Sublime 2 concept.
Fun to watch, though.
>> Well, I'm glad it's fun to watch,
at least.
Honestly, I should have put more thought
into the choice of example, I think.
The Sudoku one got pretty complicated,
pretty quick.
I think if you're going to
take away anything from this,
there's writing this function.
>> So you're screen sharing again, Andy?
>> Yeah.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It was that I wrote this function.
Check Sudoku before I
wrote these functions.
I said, I don't know what check
rows is going to look like.
I don't know how I'm going
to write check columns.
And I don't know how I'm going
to write checks squares.
But I know that if it
passes all these tests.
If my Sudoku grid passes check rows,
and it passes check columns, and
it passes check squares,
I want to return true.
>> And
that's basically the whole program.
>> Mm-hm, and
I should have said otherwise.
But that to me was
the big takeaway here.
Now when you have a really big problem,
try and
chop it up into the biggest
pieces you can at first.
Then for each of those pieces,
chop them up as big as you can.
And keep doing that and eventually
you'll get down to something where you
don't need to chop it up any more.
Where you just sort of
write a single function or
flush out a single function and
you're good to go.
So Roberta, we're going to be posting
this code and once you're free.
Feel free to go through this code and
if you have any questions on
this particular code,
post it up on the discussion forum and
we'll be more than happy to help
you walk through the code as well.
Okay, the last question of
today will be from Matt.
Are you familiar with BBEdit?
>> I'm not, so Matt, your question
is Sublime Text versus BBEdit.
I assume BBEdit is a text editor.
I honestly don't know.
Assuming it supports Python and
it's got the features you need,
you should use whatever
text editor you like.
I really like Sublime.
It's what I started using when I learned
to code and so it's just easy for
me to continue using that.
But, yeah, use whatever tools you want.
>> Yeah, so I'll just preface that.
Sublime is very good.
A lot of people in the office use it.
Other people also use other
text editors, like Notepad++.
That's actually a decent one.
Another one would be, I think.
>> Eclipse.
>> Eclipse is more heavy duty.
Okay.
>> More heavy duty,
just simple text editors with like add
on more brackets, things like that.
So like you can actually just really,
really just look up on the Internet and
basically just type in top top
five text editors for Python.
>> You get lots.
>> You could get a lot of articles,
research, and yeah.
>> If you don't have any, if you're
wondering what this conversation
is all about, use Sublime for now.
If you don't have any preference,
if you've never used
a programming environment,
it's going to be easier to just use
Sublime because that's what we're going
to be using throughout the course.
So it will just look more familiar and
be a little easier.
So stick with that.
>> Okay.
Great, so we're at 4:46 so
office hours are ending.
Our live session has ended.
Andy, do you have any final thoughts for
our students?
>> No.
I hope you enjoyed this.
And remember if you didn't take away
anything else, you can break big things
into smaller pieces even if you haven't
solved those smaller pieces yet.
>> Great, all right people.
If you have any further questions for
follow ups,
post it in the discussion forums.
It's there for
you to reach out to us, Andy and
I, as well as your fellow students.
All right, so next week we'll have
another office hour session, same time,
same day, and
we hope to see you next week.
>> Bye.
>> Bye everyone.